the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
all right my friends i am finally
getting back to my own version of game
of thrones season nine
as i'm sure most of you know by now i
have been writing my own season of game
of thrones
i thought i would throw out some ideas
about what could happen if hbo ever
decided to make another season
based on how things ended in the show i
have already wrote five episodes so far
but it has been a few weeks since i
released my last episode
i do want to apologize for taking such a
long break
as you all know there has been a lot of
news regarding house of the dragon
since i had to make so many videos about
all the new information that was coming
out i had to set this idea aside
then before i knew it a week went by and
then another week went by
now i want to get back in this because i
do want to see it through
so let's jump into my next episode of my
version of game of thrones season 9.
shall we begin the name of this episode
is the kingsguard
in the very first scene of this episode
we are back below the ground
somewhere in the north of westeros there
are several lights flickering in the
distance as seven
shadows move ahead the roots of the
werewood that are running along the
ceiling are thicker here
the red sap-like substance that was
dripping down from them is now frozen in
the shape of icicles
it looks like there are 1 000 bloody
knives hanging upside down like bats
the scene begins as we see jon ghost
tormund helen reed
and the stark guardsman sansa had sent
through the secret passageway in
winterfell's crypt
john's albino direwolf is still leading
the way when he looks back at jon
his blood red eyes glisten in the light
helen reed checks to make sure the long
item he has been carrying on his back is
still wrapped up in the furs
after he secures it again he slings it
back over his other shoulder
how did you get down here asked john
where did my sister want you to go
the commander of the stark guardsman
says we got here through winterfell
script
queen sansa wanted us to find out where
this ended we had been searching down
here for what felt like a fortnight
we ran out of food yesterday we're lucky
we ran into you when we did
i don't understand says john how did you
get here through winterfell's crypt
we found a secret passageway says the
commander of the star guardsmen
the lowest level of your family's crypt
had been collapsed
after we moved all the dirt and rubble
we found a hidden tunnel that led out
into here
john looks at helen reed and asks him
the children of the forest
helen reed begins nodding his head in
agreement that's not all we found says
the commander the star guardsmen
there are some bizarre drawings on the
wall as well drawings asked john
what were they we will show you in a
minute says the stark guardsmen
we're just about there before they take
another step forward
hallan sets his hand on jon's shoulder
then says i know you want to see your
sister
but we can't stay here long we must go
south right away
i understand says jon that's when ghosts
vanishes into the darkness that lies
ahead
after they walk another hundred feet the
stark guardsman says
it's this way he holds up his light
higher revealing the hidden passageway
that's on the left
when the six men enter they see the
small bright red eyes of ghost up ahead
the icy floor beneath their feet begins
cracking softly as they move forward
the direwolf is now sitting down as its
eyes study the wall beside him
as jon gets closer he says what is it
boy what do you see
when jon holds up his own light he sees
the drawings that were left on the wall
thousands of years ago
he sees a man standing in front of a
castle that looks a lot like winterfell
only much smaller he sees a giant
werewood surrounded by a grove of more
werewoods that are all facing inward
he then sees a child of the forest
holding the head of what looks like
another child of the forest
the commander the stark guardsman says
queen sansa was wondering what these
drawings meant
the maester sent sketches of them down
to the citadel but as far as i know
there has been no response he then looks
at jon and says
do any of you know what they mean why
would the children of the forest be head
one of their own
john looks at helen reed who doesn't say
anything right away
he grabs the long item from his back
then slings it over his other shoulder
after sucking in a deep breath helen
looks in the commander's eyes
then says we all have to make our
sacrifices he then looks away
while wiping the tears away from his own
eyes john doesn't want to ask him any
further questions
he can see that the lord is visibly
shaken he shifts his focus back at the
star guardsman
let's go find my sister says john as the
men enter the lowest level of the crypt
jon notices ghost is now sitting in
front of a statue
when jon walks over near him he says i
always wondered what was down here
i have never been on this level before
but i've seen it in my dreams
he holds up the light again now shining
it on the face made of stone
he examines the man's features for a few
moments
a sense of dread washes over jon before
he looks away from the statue's stern
face
he looks very familiar john says
nervously
well he should says tormund giantsbane
he's a stark
just like you jon starts looking behind
the statue after he notices it's been
broken
this is when helen reed says he's not in
there jon snow
this wasn't just any stark this is
brandon stark
the first stark of winterfell who was
the old king of winter
you're right says jon there isn't anyone
inside the statue
but i think there is something laying at
the bottom of it here hold this light
jon says to one of the stark guardsmen
he reaches down inside of the broken
statue then grabs what was left
behind the frost has it frozen and stiff
but the icy black leather still shines
under the flame
john unfolds it then he holds it up for
all to see it's a cloak made of black
leather and black fur
john's eyes open wide when he suddenly
realizes what it is
i've been looking at those all of my
life says storm in giant spain
that's from the night's watch it is says
john who is now looking over at howland
reed again
when i was leaving for the wall my
father john stops then corrects himself
when i was leaving for the wall lord
eddard said the starks have been manning
the wall for thousands of years
there's great honor serving in the
night's watch
the starks have manned the wall for
thousands of years
i wonder when this brandon stark was
there a very long time ago says helen
read
roughly 8 000 years ago brandon stark
was the lord commander
just like you he then looks into the
eyes of the statue's stern face
the scene ends after helen reed says he
was the 13th lord commander of the
nightfort jon snow
in the next scene we are back in the
south right outside of the castle walls
of storm's end
the sun is shining the sky is blue and
black wings and white eyes are seen
circling above suddenly the raven lets
out a loud shriek as it falls from the
sky
when the bird slams into the earth its
black feathers go flying back up into
the air
we see a foot step onto the raven before
we see a hand yank and arrow free from
the fallen bird
it's arya stark who smiles at gendry as
she sees him walking over with a few
horses
i don't want any ravens following us as
arya i will shoot down as many as i can
but will you relay the same message to
your men have them shoot down any ravens
they see
i think it would be best if bran doesn't
know when we will arrive
i will my lady says gendry and stop
calling me my lady
arya says stubbornly gendry laughs and
says i'm sorry
old habits are hard to break my men are
mounted and ready
shall we leave arya gives a head nod
then says we shall
gendry hands over the reins to a brown
stallion before climbing on the back of
his own
right over their shoulders is a very
large formation of men following behind
them
there's maybe 500 or fewer this is where
the king's road begins
the banners of house baratheon are
flapping hard in the wind
this certainly isn't the first time a
member from al stark and a member from
house baratheon went down this road
as they made their way to king's landing
in hopes of bringing back some sort of
balance to the realm
gendry looks over at arya as they ride
side by side on their
horses he says before we left king's
landing
you said you were leaving westeros and
sailing west i wasn't sure if i would
ever see you again
i know these aren't the best
circumstances but i'm glad you're here
so am i cesaria while smiling what
should i do when we arrive in the
capital ask gendry
what's your strategy will we storm the
gates will we take over the city like
our father is before us
no says arya well then good says gendry
because we don't have the numbers for
all that i will simply demand to speak
to the king says arya
i still don't actually know if it was
bran who sent the assassin to kill me
i have to keep reminding myself that the
man who attacked me might have been
lying
if only the raven wasn't following me i
know that's bran
watching over me spying on my every move
but i just don't understand why
it sounds like your brother may look at
you as a threat says gendry
arya flashes a look of doubt gendry's
way she says
why would you say something like that
well says gendry
you did kill the night king and brain
had a front row seat
he knows exactly what you're capable of
that still doesn't explain why my
brother would feel threatened by me says
arya
we weren't enemies i had no reason to
fight him
gendry looks in arya's eyes an ominous
feeling washed over him as he says
you're right arya
you had no reason to fight him but now
you do the scene ends after he says
i just hope you don't get me killed in
the following scene we go back to king's
landing to see how things are unraveling
there
the sun is sitting high in the sky
overlooking the red keep
and the city below there is still a
large crowd gathered right outside of
the castle's walls
the atmosphere in king's landing is
charged with electricity again
everyone is abuzz now that they're
wondering how and why the new master of
coin went flying from the balcony of the
king's chambers
as you can imagine rumors are already
beginning to spread across the capital
brienne and podrick are outside together
still gathering as much information as
they can
we hear one man say he heard that the
little imp had brawn killed after
fighting over an old debt that he owed
we hear a different man say he heard
braun jump because he was heartbroken
brienne immediately rolls her eyes she
did not know braun well
but she does know that would be the last
thing that would ever happen
we then hear an old woman say she heard
a thousand ravens lifted him up into the
sky
then dropped him on his head i think
we've heard enough for one day
brienne says sarcastically thank you for
the information
we will inform the king brienne then
glances over at sir podrick and says
let's go back inside
as they head for the castle's gate they
are suddenly approached by another man
who has a hood down low over his face
when he gets within a few feet of them
he holds out his fist brienne grabs the
held of her sword ready for action
but the unknown man opens his hand
dropping a crumbled note at their feet
before walking off brienne grabs the
letter from the ground then opens it
when she looks over for the hooded man
she notices he has already vanished
behind the crowd
she looks at podrick who is just as
confused as she is
brienne looks back down at the letter
then reads it aloud
it states the answers you are looking
for lie in the hands of your hand
this doesn't make any sense as brienne
the only thing in my hand
is this letter she crumbles the note in
her fist
then drops it onto the ground and walks
away wait
says sir podrick who is already grabbing
the letter and opening it again
he starts mumbling the words to himself
the answers you are looking for
lie in the hands of your hand it's just
a stupid riddle
let's go brienne says angrily this is
when podrick says we can go
but we must find lortyrion right away
they walk inside the red key
as they make their way across the throne
room dozens of ravens begin shrieking
over and over again right where the iron
throne used to sit
there must be a hundred ravens gathered
around in a circle
looking at something on the ground when
they get closer to the steps they notice
there is some blood on the floor
there is even some blood dripping down
the steps some of the ravens begin
flying away when they hear brienne
walking up the stairs
that's when she realizes they are
feasting on something
the sound of brienne unsheathing her
sword makes all of the ravens fly away
at once there is a lifeless body lying
on the ground
she looks over at podrick in disgust
unfortunately
the ravens have left this man's face
unrecognizable
even his eyes are missing the one thing
she does notice is the man
is dressed in rags that are soaked in
blood his ragged clothes are the only
thing he has left
but it doesn't help them identify who
the man was follow me
says brienne as she walks away with
urgency
they move down the hallway before they
ascend the flood of stairs that
lead to the hand of the king's chambers
when they reach lortirian's door
brianne knocks on it loudly the door
must not have been locked or
fully shut because it slowly starts to
open as they step inside they
immediately realize lorterion isn't here
however someone has recently been in
this room
everything is a mess the bed has been
knocked over and flipped upside down
the feathers that were inside his
bedding are scattered all across the
room
and everything that was inside the
dressers have been spilled out onto the
floor
someone has been in here looking for
something says brienne
his chambers did not look like this the
night we heard braun scream through the
open window
what scream a deep voice says from
behind when brianne and podrick look
back at the door
they see there are now three men
standing there watching them
brienne recognizes the men they're
leftovers from the stark's household
guard
they're the same three men who arrested
lore tyrion lannister
inside branch chambers brienne says
where did you get that armor
the men smile at each other before one
of them says
we are now sworn brothers of the
kingsguard thanks to your grace
he gave us our white cloaks then
commanded us to find you
we will need you to come with us he's
waiting for both of you
in his chambers everything inside berean
is screaming at her to grab her sword
she doesn't trust these men and she
knows it's written all over her face
she looks over at podrick who is
hesitating as well
after you my lady says one of the stark
men while stepping aside
the scene ends as they reluctantly
follow the men out of lord tyrion
lannister's chamber
in the next scene we are somewhere out
at sea it begins with us seeing an
enormous shadow flying over a fleet of
ships
drogon's black scales are shining like
obsidian under the morning sun
the dragon swoops down low over the
sails as he begins gliding over the
water below
daenerys steps out onto the deck of one
of verlor's ships
she leans against the railing before she
looks out over the deep blue sea
all around them dany smiles when she
looks at drogon
who seems to be bigger and stronger than
ever right over her shoulder are dozens
of more ships
some of them are flying the banners of
the three-headed dragon while the bulk
of them are displaying the banners of
the fiery heart
all 1000 slave soldiers from the fiery
hand are sailing with them
as well as many other followers and
high-ranking members of relore
greyworm suddenly appears from below the
deck when he spots daenerys leaning
against the railing he walks over to her
he has vowed to never leave her side
again the rest of the unsullied men are
on dany's old ships following right
behind them
as they make their way back to westeros
thank you for joining me
says daenerys when grey worm stands next
to her he bows his head
before saying your grace daenerys and
grey worm both look across the ship on
the other side of the deck
as they see kanvara walking their way
kinvara is joined by a very large man we
have never seen before
he stands well over six feet tall with
skin as black as drogon
and hair as white as snow on his face
and forehead are tattoos of red and
orange flames
the black man's red scarlet robe has
satin orange flames on it as well
in his right hand is a six foot iron
staff with a dragon's head on the end of
it
he looks spectacular in a frightening
kind of way
as they approach danny and greyworm
kenvara says your grace
i would like you to meet makaro as he
looks at danny with his shining dark
eyes
he says in his deep voice the lord of
light has shown me your worth
every night in my fires i glimpse the
glory that awaits you
kinvara then reaches out and grabs
greyworm by his arm
as she squeezes his muscles she says i
hope you and your men are ready
because darkness awaits us we are says
grey worm
he looks in dany's eyes and says you
still haven't said who we will be
fighting
kinvara smiles then she says why don't i
show you instead
she reaches down and grabs his hand grey
worm follows her over to a burning
brazier in the center of the ship
look into ralor's great fire and behold
everything that is ready to strike us
down
the red and orange flames reflecting
greyworm's eyes
his mouth hangs open as he stares into
the fire in disbelief after a few more
moments of watching
a sudden anger flashes across his face
greyworm slams the brazier down spilling
hot embers all over the deck of the ship
we see three slave soldiers of the fiery
hand rush over and begin
stomping on the embers before the wooden
ship catches fire
with the look of shock on her face danny
says what happened what did you see
whatever it was best believe you will
see it again
says makaro greyworm looks at danny his
eyes are now
filled with hatred the scene ends after
he says
i saw jon snow he was riding on the back
of drogon
in the following scene we are back in
winterfell
ghost john tormund helen reed and the
stark guardsmen emerge from below the
castle
there is so much activity in the
courtyard no one even notices them at
first
jon can't help but crack a smile when he
sees how alive the castle is again
there are men drilling with wood and
steel swords in the yard
there are cooks tending their vegetables
in the glass garden
there's restless dogs running back and
forth in the kennels
and there's even some women gossiping
beside the washing well
it almost made him feel at home again
but he remembers what helen reed said
they cannot stay here for long suddenly
he hears a surprise voice from up above
jon is that you sansa who is followed by
maester walcan
rushes down the stairs to greet him the
yard grows silent
and everyone watches as jon and sansa
embrace each other
what happened ask sansa why did you
leave castle black
jon looks at her with a bit of sadness
in his eyes he says
we have a lot to discuss he then looks
around the yard
at all the watchful eyes staring back at
him sansa finally notices everyone is
looking at them
the silence ends and everyone
immediately goes back to work now that
they have queen sansa's attention
maybe we should go speak in the godswood
says john as they begin walking
ghost starts out in front of them when
they reach the godswood ghost is already
there
sniffing the ground around the weirwood
john notices that right away
but he focuses on the task at hand your
grace i would like you to meet lord
helen reed john steps aside
while howland reed bows his head you
were friends with my father says sansa
i remember hearing stories about you
when i was younger helen reed smiles
then says i was your grace your father
was a great man
it would be an honor for me to serve his
children what brings you all this way
ass sansa
why are you with john did you join the
night's watch know your grace says lord
howland
we're here because of your brother bran
he's in grave danger
jon has agreed to help me save him or so
we hope
sansa's eyes fill with fear as she looks
over at jon
what does he mean assanza why would bran
be in grave danger
our enemies have been defeated he is
surrounded by soldiers and guards day
and night i made sure of that myself
i left behind some of our own household
guard brienne joined his kingsguard
not mine who would harm him there are
things in this world that are difficult
to explain says alan read
bran isn't the same brother you grew up
with anymore i know says sanza
bran said the exact same thing to me
when he said he was the three-eyed raven
i need you to explain it to me help me
understand
so i can help you the children of the
forest did not disappear says alan reid
your brother met some of them in a cave
beyond the wall they did everything they
could to help him defeat the night king
but it wasn't enough to end the great
war there are more children of the
forest hiding out in the south
on the isle of faces they were helping
the night king and his army of the dead
all along
they are still working against us as we
speak and they have now entered your
brother's mind
he will continue to lose more and more
of himself the longer he stays in the
south
not only is your brother in danger but
so is everyone else around him
sansa is befuddled she says what do they
want
there is a long moment of silence before
helen reed says
velar more ghoulish your grace all men
must die
we're living on their lands and they
will do everything in their power to get
them back
we have to get bran out of king's
landing before it's too late
how do we know bran hasn't left king's
landing already how do we know bran
isn't with the children of the force
right now ask sansa
there's only one way to find out says
lord helen reed he looks in john's eyes
then looks at the werewood and nods his
head in its direction
you were given the bowl of weirwood
seeds for a reason jon snow
go set your hand on its face look
through its eyes
and tell us what you see jon slowly
looks over at the white and red weirwood
he remembers what happened when he
leaned his head against one and fell
asleep
he can see ghost is still underneath it
sniffing around at the ground
he walks over next to him then kneels
down
this is very reminiscent of when john
knelt in front of the werewolf beyond
the wall
when he set his night's watch vows he
takes in a deep breath
then lays his hand over the face his
head snaps back
and his eyes roll in his head he's
immediately thrown into a vision
the first thing john sees is a massive
weirwood standing taller than any of the
other ones he's ever seen before
it's on an island surrounded by a blue
lake a very large shadow soars over the
water
and right behind that seems to be
another very large shadow
he sees seven children of the forest
standing in a circle on a beach
right behind them above the rocks is a
castle it looks a lot like dragonstone
he can see bran sitting in a weirwood
throne like the one in the three at
ravens cave
bran's eyes are rolled back in his head
he can see brawn
arguing with three star guardsmen on a
balcony overlooking a city
he then sees braun falling from that
balcony he sees greyworm standing in
front of him
he looks enraged now he sees the streets
of king's landing
right where the old septa baylor used to
sit bran
is sitting there in his wheelchair
brienne podrick and lord terry and
lannister are there as well
but before he can make out everything
that's happening he snaps out of the
visions
john's hand drops from the werewolf's
face he's now gasping for breath
everyone rushes over to him helen reed
bends down
and throws an arm over his shoulder are
you okay asks lord howland
john looks around at his surroundings
remembering where he is
he slowly controls his breathing then
says i'm fine
help me stand up helen reed and tormund
giants bane helped john back on his feet
sansa looks a bit stunned she's never
seen anything like this before
are you able to tell us what you saw
says helen reed yes says john
i did see bran he's still in king's
landing good
says helen reed we still have time i
don't think we have much time john says
doubtfully
bran had his master of coin thrown from
his balcony
why says sansa that doesn't make any
sense i don't know says john
but i think he's trying to wipe out his
entire small council
sansa is even more shocked than before
she says what makes you say that jon
what else did you see the sound of grief
comes from john's voice when he says
lord tyrion lannister has been arrested
i saw him kneeling over the
executioner's block helen reed
immediately stands back up when he hears
this
he says we must leave now everyone
begins leaving the godswood
but jon stops them before they make
another step that's not all john says
loudly
i also saw brienne and podrick they were
standing right behind lord tyrion
there is dread written all over sansa's
face after a moment of silence
sansa nervously says what happened john
the scene ends after he says they had
nooses around their necks
in the final scene of this episode we go
back inside the red keep of king's
landing
we're in king branstark's chambers on
one side of the room
bran is sitting there surrounded by his
new sworn brothers of the kingsguard
on the other side of the room brianne
and podrick are standing there
searching for answers is everything all
right your grace
asked brienne in a flat voice bran says
what would make you think something was
wrong well something is wrong says
berean
you throw samwell's book into the fire i
know i don't know you that well
but that's not like you sir boronify
garden fell from your balcony
there is a bloody dead man lying in the
old throne room lord tyrion seems to be
missing
and his chambers looked as if they have
been ramsacked i'm just trying to
understand what is happening around here
brain stares at her and looks right
through her with his unsympathetic eyes
he says it sounds like there is a ghost
inside the red key
brienne stands her ground not allowing
bran or his men to frighten her
maybe it was a ghost or maybe it was a
wolf in sheep's clothing
whereas lore tyrion bran cracks a thin
smile before
saying he's sitting in the black cells
he has been charged for the murder of
sir beron
this is nonsense shout brienne i was
with lortirian
in his chambers when we heard the scream
we ran outside together
we discovered braun's lifeless body
laying on the street below your balcony
together
i know for a fact tyrion lannister did
not do this
brain stopped smiling one of his new
kingsguard members says lady berean
cannot be trusted your grace
she has always favored the lannisters
rumor has it
she has even laid with a lannister
brienne looks at the man with eyes as
cold as ice
she says i have no love for the
lannisters
deny it all you want says bran i've seen
it myself
that sword says you're a liar did you
know that sword was made for my family's
ancestral sword
after the lannister's bastard seed
butchered my father
bran now shifts his focus over to sir
podrick he says
you're a lion as well you was once the
squire for lord tyrion lannister
and now you stand here beside another
what should i call you anyways lady
brienne
a lion in sheep's clothing brienne looks
into bran's soulless eyes
then says whatever treachery you think i
may have done
sir podrick had nothing to do with it
that's enough says the man of the king's
guard
i think they both should hang your grace
in a low voice
bran says who are you loyal to lady
brienne
who are you sworn to guard with your
life lord tyrion of house lannister
or your king you must choose here and
now
which house does that valerian steel
really fight for
what are you asking of mr grace asked
brienne
after a few moments of silence bran says
lord tyrion is to be executed for the
charge of murder
i want the lion's head mounted on my
wall will you take it for your king
or die next to him you must choose
take that sword and slay the imp or be
hanged for a betrayer
the sword or the noose brienne's eyes
fill up with water
if she wasn't frightened before she is
now
finally brienne sucks in a ragged breath
and says
i will not make that choice there was
another long silence after this
brand's new kingsguard members look at
each other in disbelief
this episode ends after brain says hang
them
[Music]
so
you